we do have to visit someone that we
haven't visited it in a while
um and that of course is
cash well it has been that long
but she did put a new video so i wanted
to watch it
of course famously gang stocked cash hey
guys
it's cash and i am here with a video for
you guys
um just because i have been talking
about a lot of stuff and i just want to
clarify a few things
so um as you guys may or may not know
um i went to cuba and
cuba is when i decided to just say hey
that's it i've had enough i walked away
because this is when things were getting
really bad for me in miami so
after i came home i came home in like
november of 2020
you know i was getting phone calls from
people
saying that people were trying to lower
the prices
which it wasn't with my old agency she
kept the prices the same it was
agents agencies um and
just people random customers would call
and say that things just
john's were subpar or they couldn't get
a hold of the upper echelon number
and just all these different things okay
so i knew that there was a reason
that i was not supposed to be there
anymore
um and as we are approaching a year
of lockdown and you know mask wearing
and stuff like that
it's become very evident to me that
you know people might not see it this
way but
we are experiencing
what america would be like under
communism
and it's not just my industry it's
everything says the person who went to
cuba for fun industry i have seen
things that have happened to me play out
with different people in different
industries
no matter what it is you know and
they're they're trying
to do things a certain way and
take it from me in my industry um it's
probably not the best way to do things
um and that's starting with
the blm communist movement
you know and people caught on to that
people do not like
the social justice the virtue signaling
if they want that stuff
they can go elsewhere for those things
so the nba
had to learn the hard way now the nba
has removed kelly loffler
the wnba has removed kelly loffler right
now
and they're also probably going to have
to learn the hard way
um so what else is going on so there's
what else well so what else is in the
news just a lot of things that i'm
seeing
that it's just and then cancel culture
so cancel culture so
basically a nobody can cancel somebody
for something
that they don't like that they did and
it's just it's becoming this is the
epidemic it's becoming a real problem
because now it's getting to it's not
even
left or right it's just somebody doesn't
like something that somebody's doing
um let's say said celebrity wants a life
of a regular person that they see on
instagram and they um we call it the
gram here honey
i don't think that they should have that
life so cancel that person
like that's where we're getting with
this whole cancel culture
it's just become like this big mess and
it's a flippin joke
and people that participate in cancel
culture
are now the ones being cancelled so
good job way to go
and what else is going on
so yeah so then you have
okay that's just a joke i'm not even
gonna talk about that
most of these people today these
celebrities oh the title of this video
for the my ideas and how they are used
without my consent so
if these ideas and i'm not even saying
she's wrong some of our ideas are good
but
this video is basically saying people
did she's coming up with these ideas and
people are using them without her
consent these
are just jokes like
literal jokes
oh and then okay so here's another thing
so
a lot of times you'll look at your
explore page
and you will see things like this
okay you gotta learn the difference
[Music]
you gotta know the difference between a
man is what it says
between a n-word and a man
okay why is this on my explore page can
somebody please tell me
and probably because you [ __ ] always
look at basic [ __ ] memes and the
algorithm picked it up
that would be my guess if that word is a
forbidden word
why is that word being used in memes
why is that word okay to be on the
internet
but i think a more important question is
[Music]
what was the name of hp lovecraft's cat
according to quora the name of the cat
has often been cited in discussions of
lovecraft's racial attitude
that's google that's not me it's not
okay to be said
okay so this is my problem with it and
this was my response to that
i said stop using the word if you don't
want other people using it based
i've openly told black people not to use
that word around me
you put [ __ ] out there in music on
explore page and everywhere else
subliminally targeting people into
saying that word
when you stop the world stops so
it's not really the fact that black
people
don't like that word being said it's the
fact
that the power of that word let's see
what google says about that
[Music]
what is the n word here's the definition
of
n word informal used instead of or in
reference to the word
because of its taboo nature
google not me youtube suck a [ __ ]
[ __ ]
that's you you are using that google
not me not me i just asked a question
and then google goes out and they
[ __ ] say it and i'm that [ __ ] sounds
white
i don't think she has an n-word pass
being said
they can attack the person who said it
that's the only thing that it is they
really don't care because if they cared
that much about that word
they would not be using it and all their
songs and
you know things like that so it's really
not it's a weapon
that word is a weapon for them basically
is what it comes down to because then
here comes lamarcus
with
lamarcus i wonder what he's going to say
uh did you really just say
during black history month yeah [ __ ]
[ __ ] and you know what
i can't believe i'm doing this but i'm
team cash right now is anybody else team
cash right now besides me
because i [ __ ] am hey lamarcus cash
could say whatever the [ __ ] she wants
how about that doesn't matter what
[ __ ] month it is
all right i don't care who invented the
stoplight
no i didn't i i said exactly what the
post said i did not say it
so that's a problem don't like that
then next your communi i said your
communist rules don't apply
to me because it is a communist thing
telling someone they can't say a certain
word is censorship
okay god this video i think i think
we're team
cash in this video right so far so far
i'm team cash
that's lack of freedom of speech and
yeah so more stuff and then this is
something
that i see a lot
let's go okay so let's get rid of the
communism
okay because we've experienced it it
sucks
i know everybody is not having a good
time i am
not having a good time right now um then
i see
megan rapinoe and sue bird are the most
beloved power couple in sports
who most beloved is
a stretch most beloved
um i don't think so are they a respected
couple coupling sports sure absolutely
you know they're both great athletes
but to say that they are the most
i don't think so and that's where the
media
you know they need to be i call it the
lame stream media censored themselves
because they create these narratives i
can think of people you know maybe their
spouse
isn't a um
an athlete but as far as the most
beloved i would say it's probably mia
ham and nomar garcia para
you know like i'm just tired of being
told what's the most
and what's this and what's that like
it's just getting old to me
and then here after i go on my
that i went on on social media here we
go
perfect right here kevin durant responds
to cash doll
after she tweets lyrics with katie's
initials
kevin durant had a bit of advice when
cash dow tweeted
all these ends
wanna f k d it's
easy to guess why the brooklyn nets
player was slightly miffed since he's
known by the same
initials okay so first of all
cash doll's name is our keisha
okay um her name isn't even cash doll
so this whole thing is stupid and that's
where it comes into
like just like
so this is what this is what cash is
saying for those of you that are trying
to keep score at home
um as you can see this is cash over here
all right and she's calling this
gentleman over here clearly a black
gentleman the n word and think she
thinks that she has
the right to do it because she's cash
money
[Music]
cash money look at that
so she's allowed to do it all right for
those of you keeping score i just want
to make sure that you guys know that's
what's going on
media have nothing to report on because
i was pretty much
posting things like this in
my news feed all day okay
old pictures i was having an l bundy day
old pictures no peg
like when i was dancing and stuff
because you know the industry
has just gone up in smoke that's her
bush between her legs is her bush
and then all of a sudden this is what's
in the news
is this and i'll post a video that i
made
about this down below um
but it's just like
it's just frustrating man that sounds
like it we're frustrated it sounds like
they take regular people's lives okay
things that they like
from a regular person's life and then
use
them like these celebrities with no
talent with nothing original about them
use that narrative and that storyline
and i'm just kind of getting sick of it
like i'm over here like i'm trying to
like write books and things and i'm
seeing
things that i'm right guys she's an
author writing in my books
play out in front of on television i
don't want to be anybody's muse
i i'm not someone's muse i'm my own muse
well
i'm sorry to tell you this uh cash but
as you can see
you're my muse see she's my muse
look at that you have been my muse for a
while actually and i
i look i i get that you don't want to be
but you can't help it when you're
somebody's muse that's not really your
choice
create on my own so the fact that these
people these talentless
disgusting people are taking
things ripping things off from actual
talented people is wrong and
somebody needs to speak up about it
somebody needs to do something about it
because it's the epidemic it's the
problem
so with that said i hope that everybody
has a wonderful day
and god bless
she's mad i mean she's based but she's
mad
hey guys it's cash so if you've been
watching
my social media um or looking at my
posts you know i've been posting a lot
of things
about like these celebrities these
artists and stuff
i'm an artist and mainly it's because
just as of late you know i've been
seeing like
videos i've been seeing and this isn't
the first of this i made a whole video
on this when i was in miami
so i'll post that down below okay but
now
like i'm kind of tired of this um i'm
kind of tired
of my life the prior 10 years of my life
being used for inspiration in
you know basically talentless musicians
music videos do i think
[Music]
so she thinks that musicians and rappers
and stuff are
are using her as as what
like they're watching her videos and
making music videos out of her
i'm just trying to understand i think
that cardi b
is harassing me and stalking me no i
don't think that but
i do think that she has fans you know
that do go after
certain people harass them
[Music]
so because cardi b going after you be
ridiculous but what's not ridiculous is
cardi b has fans that she has attacking
you
cardi b has fans that are attacking you
[Music]
i think that the people that are in
charge of her career
um they pay attention to people who have
actually
done this job meaning her
for long periods of time and they take
certain things
from people's social medias and lives
that have actually done this job
and put these things in her videos and
like i was just watching her new video
the other day and it's like
they like scrolled through my instagram
page
and took certain things that i've done
in my life
while in this industry and just like put
it in this music
could it be that prostitutes and stuff
a lot of them do similar things
because would just be me i'm just
guessing here i'm not positive
but could it be the prostitutes and
stuff just happen that a lot of them
live the same lives
video and like while other people may
find that
flattering and things like that cardi b
stealing from her folks that's what
she's trying to say
not um i'm my own muse and
like i said before like i have i made
that blog
i wrote that blog and then all of a
sudden things that i wrote in the blog
were showing up on television
okay so what does that tell me about yes
adam she's the only one ever receive a
cleveland steamer
the entertainment industry they are
ripping off people's actual
lives they go on social media that's
what social media is all about
so if you're posting things about your
life there's a good chance
without your knowledge that those things
that you're posting
are being used in television shows
you know to just to inspire things and
that's great but
you should know about it you should be
compensated for it
okay and i'm just getting really sick of
it because these people are getting paid
okay and we are not and
it's just it's very unfair to see
um somebody that most likely didn't live
this life you know because i and i've
made a video about that i'll attach that
down below
most likely didn't live this life
because everything that she's doing
in her career is that
like she's still a stripper like only
fans and this is about cardi b
only fans she's on only fans you know
she wants to plan parties still
you know she's talking about how she
could be the best party planner things
like that
you know and then she has like these
girls you know that
idolize her and she really like her
music
her music is her music message just
sucks
okay point blank just sucks um
and she is just not a good role model
and kids should not be looking up to a
person like this
okay a person that is obviously
controlled
by a lot of people a person that has
people that rip ideas off of other
people's
lives okay because she can't produce
something from her own life
authentically that people will like and
it's just i'm tired of it
so that's what all these posts on social
media
so cardi b's people not her because
cardi that would be ridiculous
are scrolling through her instagram
to find stuff
to find stuff to then
steal her things and not compensate her
to put him in music videos
have been about um this is a growing
problem
um some people they they don't mind it
they think it's cool
like oh you know they use my whatever
you know they see it and like they think
it's a coincidence it's not a
coincidence
your social media is being used to
get ideas for these talentless
uncreative people
because you ever notice how hollywood
only has
they have 20 game shows but there's only
four hosts
for these shows okay yeah i mean that's
been going on forever though
okay like ellen and jimmy kimmel and
why why do you have 20 game shows and
only three or four hosts
are hosting these shows i mean usually
those are under the same contract for
the same network and it's just cheaper
to throw a game show at them than kai or
somebody new
because you have to be one of these
creepy pedophile
degenerate weirdos in order to do
anything in hollywood anymore
that's why it's become so fake and phony
that they have to keep it to their
little you know
of people because even wayne brady
because these people are fake they're
phony they are not
real people and they are taking ideas
from real people
okay so that's all i have to say about
that i hope that everybody has a
wonderful day
i mean i will now cash thank you so much
i don't know all these things were going
on behind the scenes